[Aplausos]
eu sou professora e eu lembro muito bem
da primeira vez que eu fui dar mal em
curso de pós graduação
estava tão nervosa tão nervosa em
piracicaba interior de são paulo
nenhum ônibus sexta feira cheguei na
rodoviária e aí peguei um táxi na
rodoviária um taxista senhora bem
simpático ele virou pra mim e falou
assim você vê o passeio ele não vinha
trabalho
sou professora flávia sonho de criança
eu falei não não sou professora de gente
grande mesmo
é eu vim da uac na universidade
ele deu uma paradinha e diminuiu a
velocidade do carro olhou para trás e
falou off a você acha que alguém te leva
a sério a sessão uma moça e o que já
estava nervosa e né
enfim eu percebi mesmo que não importava
muito quanto eu tivesse estudado sobre
ação rescisória no processo do trabalho
quero tema da aula eu precisava chegar
lá e provar primeiro que eles podiam
acreditar no de uma moça diria sobre a
ação rescisória no processo do trabalho
bom essa história tem muito a ver com o
que eu queria contar pra vocês hoje
falar um pouquinho sobre o que o
carinhosamente denominei de escalada dos
vulneráveis gente é muito bom tem medo é
muito saudável ter medo é natural né
o medo que eu tive as inseguranças que
tive antes daquela aula assim como as
que eu tive tenho aqui nos bastidores e
no palco agora são super importantes
para que a gente se desafio para a gente
construir mais pra gente fazer coisas
melhores
acontece que algumas pessoas receberam
receberam uma das espécies de
inseguranças extras da vida existe uma
construção né ideológica social de
alguma
pessoas já nascem devendo alguma coisa a
gente tem de ouvir muito falar em
minorias né pra falar de nós mulheres
para falar de negro para falar de gay
pra falar de pessoa com deficiência
corde latino africano e asiático
o direito hoje em dia prefere usar a
expressão grupos vulneráveis porque nem
sempre a gente a minoria numérica não é
hoje nesse palco por sinal
somos maioria mas isso não faz com que a
gente deixe de ser um grupo que seja um
eterno alvo de discriminação e de uma
dupla caminhada de um duplo esforço pra
alguma coisa que outras pessoas
conseguem com um passo só eu queria ser
imaginassem comigo uma idéia vamos lá
que a vida é uma escalada da montanha
não sentido de competição nada disso
quem é mais rápido tem nada a ver com
isso mas num caminho é um caminho que
vai ter o desafio vai ter um buraco vai
ter coisa você tropeçar e lá em cima
eu não gosto de pensar muito na idéia de
sucesso a 1 em cima do meu sucesso
porque eu acho que o sucesso é aquilo
que os outros acham da nossa trajetória
eu gosto de pensar realização realização
é o que a gente acha netão a nota
daquela montanha tem realização tem
realização pessoal tem realização
profissional
na base dessa montanha tem um ponto de
partida e esse ponto de partida é
ocupado por um sujeito que a gente vai
chamar hoje de sujeito ideal é aquele
cara que não nasceu devendo nada pra
ninguém
ele tá zerado eu duvido que eu acho um
aqui hoje aquele cara ele processo como
um inconsciente coletivo ou até para um
triste consciente coletivo ele está
impecável ele está zerado construir esse
cara ficará é mulher e ficar a mulher é
uma boa pergunta
a mulher não é homem ele é negro não é
branco
ela é gay não ele é hétero
ele é obeso é magro ele é magro
ele é latina é a américa latina ea
áfrica e asiático não é norte americano
e europeu e mesmo sendo europeu ele é
croata grego português não vamos fazer a
pessoa completa ele é francês alemão
inglês não mas não não ter alguma pessoa
com menos do que isso ele tem alguma
síndrome
ele tem alguma deficiência não sei se
tem algum aqui mas toda falta de
parabéns
é esse cara tá lá a gente eu não estou
dizendo que a vida dele seja fácil eu
não estou dizendo que a escalada deles
seja um mar de rosas não a vida dele
também vai ter um monte de encrenca
mas um grande ele não tem ele não provar
para ninguém que ele é bom o suficiente
só na carreira nesses caminhos nessa
montanha que a gente falou
essa é a base acontece que tem uma outra
montanha aqui com outra base
essa montanha chamaria de uma escalada
prévia é uma escalada que tem uma galera
que tem que fazer para aprovar só que
ela pode ser tão boa quanto o sujeito
ideal
olha desculpa apesar de eu ser mulher
eu acho que eu posso chegar aqui do lado
desse cara sabe eu acho
apesar de uma brasileira que mora na
europa e dos olhares tortos que eu
recebo eu acho que eu posso ficar aqui
eu acho que eu posso talvez pensar em
escrever uma coluna aqui no jornal de
portugal
bom eu vou partir gente da minha
vivência como mulher que eu acho que o
grupo vulnerável mais relevante ao qual
eu pertenço
mas essa idéia eu continuo sendo uma uma
brasileira na europa enfim pertence a
outros grupos mas essa idéia que eu vou
falar agora serve pra vocês transporem
para qualquer grupo ao qual vocês
pertençam e é muito interessante uma
coisa que uma amiga minha dizia que eu
não esqueci ela falou assim a mulher que
diz que nunca se sentiu discriminado
discriminada é uma mulher extremamente
[Música]
distraída
assim como um negro que sinta a mesma
coisa assim como um gay que sinto a
mesma coisa e qualquer pessoa né que
pertence a um grupo vulnerável a
qualquer um né
ainda minoria pra gente chamar assim pra
ficar mais fácil a gente tem que tomar
muito cuidado gente porque é muito
cansativo seja um grupo vulnerável é
muito cansativo e às vezes a gente tem
uma tendência a fechar os olhos para
certas coisas por uma questão de
sobrevivência de autopreservação sabe
porque é muito chato a gente passa todo
dia
reconhecendo as pequenas grandes lesões
que fazem a gente a vida começa a ver
uma batalha sabe e é natural a gente
fechar os olhos não tudo bem acho que
está tudo bem embora segue jogo sabe aí
percebi que o animal joga para baixo do
tapete está tudo bem eu entendo eu
também faço isso mas a gente não pode se
deixar pensar que a discriminação estão
diminuindo essa coisas estão ficando
mais tranquilo estou mais light porque a
gente fecha o olho mesmo ea gente tem
que ter a consciência que a gente não
precisa até o oriente médio a gente não
precisa e até a áfrica a gente não
precisa ter o sertão do nordeste está
aqui
aqui todo dia às discriminações as novas
lesões estão aqui todo dia ela acompanha
a gente a cada passo
eu gosto de duas histórias minhas nem eu
não gosto nada delas na verdade desculpa
eu detesto elas duas mas eu acho que
elas são bem oportuna que me fizeram ter
uma dimensão muito forte muito sólida de
como as coisas ainda são
quando eu era estagiária outro dia 10
anos é é quando era estagiária o meu
chefe me deu essa taxa era de um juiz
muito legal e o mp é uma atribuição que
adorava eu ia até a porta quando chegava
a um advogado para receber os advogados
falarem com ele eu gostava mesmo de
fazer isso porque eu ia votar no doutor
é é urgente esse processo do juiz mesmo
não é só pegar nada lá embaixo me
explicar um pouquinho do caso eu avisava
o juiz a pessoa entrava muito bem e
chegou estagiário novo depois de um ano
eu já trabalhava
e aí eu já falou roth leva a estar junto
com você que aí ele vai aprendendo né
como é que faz a triagem a itown legal
me senti meu professor e foi a primeira
vez que a gente chegou lá a gente chegou
os dois falou batalha de tutor
o advogado falou boa tarde e se dirigiu
ao menino não a mim eu sei um pouco
esquisito aqui eu entrei tal daqui a
pouco chega outra divulgada foi mas nós
não votarmos doutora e ela boa tarde pra
ele
boa tarde queria falar com o juiz que eu
acho que eu fui percebendo que eu
comecei a ficar meio peixe fora d'água
nas conversas que era muito mais fácil
as pessoas confiarem no moleque de terno
do que em nome da sapatilha que fiquei
tão mal aquilo eu fiquei tão mal lembrou
eu chorei não voltando pra casa aquele
dia eu falei isso vai passar
isso é porque eu sou nova e isso não vai
ficar assim
dez anos depois agora há pouco tempo eu
fui junto com meu sócio
a gente tem escritório de advocacia
junto 50% das cotas cada um metade cada
um
a gente foi uma reunião no sindicato
patronal quer um cliente
fizemos a reunião falando que a gente
achava que eu achava ele achava tudo
certo e aí quando acabou a reunião o
presidente do sindicato vira pra ele
falou assim
doutor eu me dá seu cartão então nem meu
sócio procurando gols e que está sem
cartão e ele vai pedir desculpas e sim o
presidente sindicato educadíssimo ou não
não nos preocupe doutor não se preocupe
põe a mão no meu ombro e fala meu anjo
eu gosto dessa dicotomia né doutor meu
anjo tornou são 50% das cotas
ele põe a mão no meu ombro e falar meu
anjo
depois e me passa e meio então os
contatos do doutor
a minha sorte foi que antes eu ter
qualquer razão meu sócio virou e falou
assim não não sou desculpe não a doutora
tem coisa mais importante para fazer o
escritório eu mesmo humanos meus
contatos e aí eu percebi que dez anos
depois eu ainda era só uma moça que nem
motorista do táxi falou que daqui a 10
anos e daqui a mais 10
sempre que eu tiver que rolar de um cara
eu vou continuar sendo uma moça
eu acho que aqui a gente chega na
questão central dessa conversa de uma
professora no quinto ano da faculdade
disse uma coisa que eu nunca mais que
assim ela falou quanto mais emancipada é
uma mulher maior é responsabilidade dela
de lutar pela emancipação das outras
isso é muito importante
isso é muito importante porque a questão
é a seguinte eu fiz lá minha escalada
prévia né eu fiz e e eu cheguei ali
mesmo na base da outra montanha
cheguei gente não só por mérito meu mas
sim também por uma série de privilégios
os quais eu uso o frio ao longo da minha
vida
nascido em uma família de classe média
alta com acesso ao ensino boas escolas
há cursos de língua eu cheguei eu
cheguei eu sou sócia de quase um sujeito
ideal ele só não é europeu mas é tudo
isso eu sou sócio dele eu tô lá né
e aí eu pergunto pra vocês agora que eu
cheguei aqui eu tô vendo a montanha
lá na minha frente nessa colunista de
jornal caramba aqui na hora
e aí eu olho pra frente qualquer meu
papel a gente agora é subir é subir
escalar e não olhar mais para trás e
desencanado aquela montanha que está ali
será que é esse o meu papel agora ou
será que eu ainda tenho algum papel um
papel importante de voltar até aquela
montanha e jogar uma corda e tentar
puxar mais gente comigo
a ikea boazinha ela né pessoa generosa
talvez não seja nem isso gente talvez
seja porque a gente tem que adquirir a
consciência de que enquanto eu for uma
mulher uma pessoa vulnerável ao lado de
trocentos sujeito ideais
eu sou visita né
eu tô pedindo licença é uma desculpa
desculpa tá aqui mas eu acho que eu
posso estar aqui agora quando começa a
trazer mais mulher comigo e mais gay e
mais negro e mais gente com deficiência
mais asiático e mais muçulmana mas judeu
evangélico todo mundo
quando eu trago essa galera toda comigo
será que eu não começo a desconstruir um
pouco essa idéia de que o ideal é ele
se nós já somos tantos aqui juntos a
gente já tá todo mundo na base dessa
montanha será que esse delta certo
percebem isso que é mais fácil escalar
grupo do que ficar lá sozinho o que eu
acho interessante é que a gente ainda
caem muitas ciladas
a gente ainda tem muitos clichês né por
exemplo quem é que nunca houve uma
mulher falar a não é só a mulher maçã no
gosto muito de trabalhar com mulher é
muito difícil saber o nome disso auto
sabotagem
você está dizendo que é ruim trabalhar
com você
até quando a gente vai ouvir coisa desse
tipo até quando a gente vai ouvir falar
não tudo bem ele ser gay né mas a
notícia da pinta no escritório até
quando a gente vai ouvir falar não tem
problema nenhum com o negro imagina mas
eu não sei se os clientes estão
preparados para encontrar ele na reunião
adoro nordestina mas é trabalho mas
jogar dinheiro né
sabe esse tipo de coisa até quando a
gente vai cair nessa ciladas nas quais a
gente joga cada um de nós mais para
baixo na nossa montanha e fortalece cada
vez mais um sujeito ao qual teoricamente
a gente está devendo coisas
até quando a gente vai ter que sentir
que a gente nasceu endividam se a gente
nasceu
sendo menos do que a gente devia ser até
quando gente a gente vai aceitar perder
um tempo tão valioso de vida escalando
uma montanha que nem devia tá ali
obrigada
[Aplausos]